Speaker 1: All right.
Let's go next and talk to.
Let's go to Chuck from Pittsburgh.
Chuck, you're on the air.
Speaker 5: Hey, David Pakman.
Yes, I can.
So I don't really have any questions, but
I just kind of had some thoughts to put out
there.
One is like, we have like all these people
on the right that talk about like they're
pro-life and stuff.
Yeah.
And I've never heard any like I wonder what
their views would be because I feel like a
lot of these people are also like racist.
Like what's their what's their views on like,
like racist pro-life?
Cause I feel like a lot of these people don't
like black people or Jews.
And, you know, like what were their what do
you what do you think their views on that
would be?
Speaker 1: What?
I don't even know what are their views on
racist pro-life?
What does that mean?
Speaker 5: Well, so like a lot of, I feel
like a lot of racists are also on the right
and a lot of like pro-life people are on the
right.
Yeah, like the that aren't for abortion.
So like, what were their thoughts be on like
a black person having an abortion?
Like do they even care?
Or you know what I mean?
Speaker 1: Well, they claim to and then this
is actually something that the pro-life right
will use.
They'll say abortion is incredibly racist
because look at the use of abortion by black
pregnant women, and it's it's it's particular.
So they whether they're racist or not, they
pretend or claim to be concerned about aborted
black babies as part of their anti-abortion
stance now.
You know, whether they're genuine in that
concern or not is a totally different question.
Speaker 5: They're basically just playing
alone to act like they care about their their
views.
Speaker 1: Well, I don't.
I don't want I can't say they claim to care.
I think is the point and whether they do or
don't, I don't know.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
And then just another thing, too, like I'm
from Pittsburgh to that bridge, that bridge
collapse.
Yeah, I saw on Facebook a lot of people were
like commenting on the thing, and a lot of
people are just complaining about like, you
know, we pay taxes and why wasn't this taken
care of?
And it's like, I feel like a lot of these
people also don't realize that like, like
I understand, the bridge was in poor condition,
but like also like you could just have like
a bridge that was in great condition and accidents
can happen.
Speaker 1: Like, yeah, statistically speaking,
I mean, we have sort of a normal distribution
where like for the most part, if the bridges
are fine, they're not going to collapse every
once in a while.
You get bridges in terrible shape that don't
collapse, and every once in a while you get
a bridge.
That's OK as far as engineers are concerned
and it does class.
But correct me if I'm wrong, the bridge that
collapsed did not have a good structural rating,
did it?
Did it not?
Speaker 5: Correct.
Correct.
Yeah, it was in poor condition.
Yeah.
I was just saying there, like, I saw all these
people commenting about like, you know, I
can't believe they would let this happen and
stuff.
And it's like, Well, yeah, it was in poor
condition.
But like, I mean, accidents can happen.
It could have been in great condition in that,
too.
Yeah, it could.
Speaker 1: And also, there's dozens of I mean,
there was a report there's like dozens or
even hundreds of bridges in New Jersey with
the exact same condition, and they'll mostly
be fine.
But this could happen again at any time.
Speaker 5: Yeah, exactly.
But yeah, I mean, like I said, I didn't really
have any questions been watching since probably
about the beginning of the pandemic when everybody
kind of hyper focused on politics.
Yeah, because of all that.
So but yeah, I'm a member like the show and
just keep up the good work.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thanks, Chuck.
Very much.
Appreciate it.
That's going to do it for calls today.
We will take a quick break and be back with
much more.
And if you didn't get on today, there will
be more opportunities